[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it is the 31st of March 2014 the first
day of what was to become the longest
jury hearing in British legal history
it's got to be the truth we need to get
justice for I loved ones so they can
rest the future he had a family
he had friends you had everything go for
them you've gotta have to be prepared
for some dreadful things there's no hook
the mouse I believe it was there inquest
the police the last one in 91 and this
one is for the 96 in a converted office
block on an industrial estate in
Warrington families bereaved by the
disaster were the first to be called to
new inquests they took the jury back to
the day of the tragedy it was a lovely
sunny day I was up early so I had
actually gone to wake him up to see what
time he wanted to go but he didn't need
to be up that early so I'll let him go
back to sleep and I headed off to
Manchester about 8 o clock in the
morning
sooo Roberts older brother Graham had
arranged to travel to the Hillsborough
Stadium in Sheffield with a group of
mates his beloved Liverpool FC had
reached the semi-final of the FA Cup for
the second year running I didn't know
anything was wrong until five o'clock as
I was leaving to come home and my friend
was driving and the radio was on and she
was going to play a cassette and I just
said no can relieve the radio one
because Graham was there
[Applause]
the crust
[Applause]
another Liverpool fan Tony barn Rock was
all too aware of what was going on at
the Hillsborough Stadium he was in the
same area as Graham Roberts the central
pens of the lettings Lane Terrace
couldn't move just couldn't get anywhere
just like you know mass of the seconds
you've ever go squeeze and three people
are doing you save too much to just bang
[Applause]
you couldn't go up for forward sideways
backwards anyway just have to get in
Satan and Satan and say sir I was up in
the air I was facing away from the pit
to understand why such crushing had
occurred you'd have to look at events
earlier in the afternoon the carnival
atmosphere had started to turn tents as
turnstiles struggled to process the
large crowds in an effort to ease the
flow an exterior gate was opened similar
action had been taken in previous years
but this time no effort was made by the
police to seal the central tunnel
leading to already overcrowded tents at
3:15 in this police control box match
commander David duckenfield told the
chief executive of the Football
Association that fans had gained entry
he didn't say that the gate was opened
on his instructions
many rank-and-file officers meanwhile
were dealing with the dead and dying one
of those officers was special constable
Deborah Martin there was no coordination
this time there they'd Pat them to
overcapacity and that's when I could
hear the screaming
that's when I realized that because
they've been packed in like sardines it
was a domino effect and that's when I
saw people literally squashed it begins
the fence Ain the terror within the
central towns at Leppings Lane
intensified as Tony Barbra started
hearing bones breaking including these
are lies with his arm around and with
the closure people sat across make these
like three people trying to get out of a
gate for one don't think it every man
for themselves which you would be and is
that I've just cracked and smashed me
but he brought me staying and a couple
days as he thought it is that I was down
the barrier and was just napping severe
then a Madison get him up by his hair I
pulled you over
I went and turned the telly on chaos and
the emergency number was popping up on
the television screen and so we started
phoning friends and family were phoning
us to see if we'd heard any news at the
stadium attempt tree mortar II had been
set up in the gym
Debra Martin found herself in the midst
of the most harrowing scenes it was just
a mess in the gym there was no
organization at all who as he came we
were just putting people down there
trying to do some sort of segregation
but at the end of it it was just a mess
one of the victims was 15 year old Kevin
Williams identified here in a clip shown
to the inquest story his case was to
become crucial in eventually undermining
the verdict of accidental death at the
original inquest I noticed that he was
going blue round the lips so I had to do
CPR again I did click at the chest
compressions but he was deteriorating at
the time I remember trying it twice more
and that's when I realised that Kevin
was dying and I just remember this
little boy he was laid in my arms and he
just looked straight at my his eyes
actually opened and he looked straight
at me and his last words was mum Kevin
Williams aged 15 had become one of the
96 as had graham Roberts
we're taken into a room and there was a
glass screen the length of one of the
walls on the other side of the glass
screen there was curtains and there was
stupid pipe music playing and then
deaths worried ready and the curtains
were drawn back and sadly there was grey
and lion honor it's obviously still the
worst moment of my life you don't expect
to see you big brother
you'd only gone to a football match
lurid and inaccurate stories followed
quoting police sources it fueled the
toxic atmosphere and Families believed
that when it came to dealing with
officialdom they paid a devastating
price when it was explained who we were
we were told to sit in the corner and we
was just sat down in a corner of this
police station as my dad used to
describe it with the Saturday night
drunks who'd never been treated like
decent human beings you'd think we were
hooligans you'd think we were thugs you
wouldn't have thought we were bereaved
family members as far as families were
concerned verdict of accidental death at
the original inquest added insult to
injury they became increasingly
concerned at the coroner's decision not
to accept evidence from after 3:15 on
the day of the disaster
he'd concluded that by then all of those
who died had suffered irreversible
injuries Deborah Martin believes that
her statement saying the dying boy had
spoken to her half an hour after that
point had become inconvenient
she told the inquest that she was
visited by an investigating officer
basically she said that statement I've
made didn't hold true and there was a
lot of faults in it and the only way to
rectify it was by having a new statement
and as I said too at the time and I
stand by my original statement I'm not
doing it I want you to go and that's
when the badgering started that's when I
found out what another police officer
could do to another police officer and
it was horrible it was name-calling and
I wasn't very good at my job I didn't
know what I was doing I was very mixed
up and I wasn't aware of what it
occurred it Hills breath
I had to sign it yeah I signed it under
duress I didn't want to do it but if
that was the only way of getting rid of
this woman who was basically calling me
a liar and that I didn't and I just
actually fabricated everything and she
broke my former West Midlands sergeant
Julie Appleton strongly rejected the
accusations saying she had every
sympathy for the experience Deborah
Martin had been through and she denied
bullying her on her behalf the Police
Federation said she's given live
evidence to the inquests she's provided
two written statements to the
Independent Police Complaints Commission
and operation resolve and won't be
making any further comment but Deborah
Martin is not the only former South
Yorkshire officer to have criticized
police handling of the hills but
disaster and it's aftermath
inspector Clive Davis told the new
inquests that his bosses were determined
virtually from the outset that fans
would take the birth
[Applause]
and the story emerges that one of the
outside gates leading into that Terrace
was broken people without tickets got in
were therefore overcrowding the people
with tickets and that's why the crash
occurred
[Applause]
even as people lay dying at Hillsboro
the claims blaming fans had started to
spread rapidly and began to take hold
[Applause]
Metropolitan Police Officer Keith Lee he
attended the recent Hillsborough
memorial service at Liverpool he knows
better than most why football supporters
went straight into already overcrowded
pens 27 years earlier he was among them
and like hundreds of others couldn't see
an alternative route I went through that
gate that was opened and just went down
a tunnel it's one you think you saw when
you walked in for the Gators that just
it's all open so just walked in felt
like a just a normal game and so we got
inside it was off then I could sell then
it was thought it was too many people
there and it was just way applies then
it was just under the borders
I'm very nearly never came home this is
all those people that didn't I was that
far away
it's in the middle of it all in the
latins lane I've come here every year
since because it could have been me and
obviously this is an extremely emotional
occasion for you very much so yeah yeah
as grief-stricken fans and Families
mourned in Hillsborough Mediate
aftermath pressure was already mounting
to quickly establish the cause at the
Sheffield Stadium on the day after the
event the Prime Minister Margaret
Thatcher was briefed by a team which
included the match commander David
duckenfield I felt we had to come first
to get South Yorkshire police knew well
that their actions would come under
intense scrutiny it was vital that they
got their story right the Police
Federation made it clear that story was
vast majority of that lot had been
drinking the ones that were arriving
late and they will not be told where to
go they won't do anything you're trying
to do Clive Davis is one of just a few
former officers to speak out about
Hillsborough he claims that two days
after the disaster one of his bosses for
then Chief Inspector Norman better s'en
invited him to a meeting at Force
Headquarters he thought it would be
beneficial to us from a career point of
view if we both went to that meeting I
didn't read anything into that
particularly because clearly this was
going to be big this was going to be the
biggest thing ever to affect and impact
all on this organization Chief
Superintendent Terry Wayne allegedly led
the meeting he began to speak about the
fact that the organisation was putting
her he'd been asked by the Chief
Constable to get a team together to put
a team together to prepare a police
response to what had actually happened
at on the Saturday some of the words
still ring in my ears now that basically
we were going to put the blame for this
disaster where it belonged on drunken
ticketless Liverpool supporters the now
retired Chief Superintendent Terry Wayne
turned down our request for an interview
but he told the inquests he was not
involved in the hills brain
investigation at the relevant time the
former chief inspector and subsequently
knighted Sir Norman better s'en also
rejected our interview request he was
asked at the inquests if his work had
involved an attempt to blame Liverpool
fangs he said let me be clear I am not
embarrassed by the issue I was not part
of some black propaganda unit to put the
blame on the fans
job Horrocks was just a child when his
father Arthur died for the survivors
were blades plate or the earth said you
have pickpocketed and he would see when
others offered doing this no tickets
there's too many they were altar all
like his father before him John Horrocks
became an ardent Liverpool football
supporter so go the game think because
we want to scatter his ashes and I'm
filled in the goal cop end you see sort
of there but he could have been there
with me next to me standing next to me
watching the game with me in the years
that followed the disaster it emerged
that officers had been discouraged from
criticizing senior colleagues according
to one report a hundred and sixty-four
statements from officers were picked out
for amendment of those a hundred and
sixteen were changed to remove
unfavorable comments about South
Yorkshire Police the word chaotic for
example was taken out despite that a
Labour government decided in the late
1990s to draw a line under Hillsborough
and D Burnham was an aspiring though as
yet unelected empty I remember the day
that that happened I pulled over in my
car I was out and I think in the middle
of I think I was in Sheffield in fact on
that day and I remember weeping in the
lay-by just thinking why because that
promise to reopen Hillsborough was a
huge reason for enthusiasm in 1997 and
when that happened I just thought how
can that be right he could not have
known then that more than ten years
later as culture secretary he would
stand before Liverpool fans at Anfield
in an event to mark the 20th anniversary
of the hills but disaster 20 years ago
nor could he have known that he would
face head-on the frustration of football
fans and families who had lost faith in
politicians the justice system and the
established
[Applause]
in response Andy Burnham helped
establish complete transparency with
disclosure of all the documents and
footage
the government waived secrecy rules and
the result was the Hillsborough
independent panel report it concluded
that a less chaotic emergency response
may well have saved lives and from the
mass of evidence nothing other than a
few isolated examples of drunkenness and
violence from Liverpool supporters the
Prime Minister's response was clear so
on behalf of the government and indeed
our country I am profoundly sorry that
this double injustice has been left
uncorrupted for so long
the original verdict of accidental death
was subsequently quashed the police
finally held up their hands and released
this unequivocal statement on that day
South Yorkshire police failed victims
and families the police lost control in
the immediate aftermath senior officers
sought to change the record of events
disgraceful lies were told which blamed
Liverpool fans for the disaster families
believed that justice was getting closer
at the new inquests Hillsborough match
commander David duckenfield accepted for
the first time that he had not told the
truth about the cause of the disaster
and he apologized to families some were
overwhelmed
you just mixed with emotions you know
because you've got to start thinking of
the people who have gone who wanted to
hear them word I'm not heard them where
they died tormented but when we visited
David duckenfield home he was not keen
to expand on why he had waited so long
to put the record strive some of his
former colleagues took a less apologetic
approach at the inquests despite the
earliest statement from South Yorkshire
police they repeated allegations of
drunkenness and bad behavior by fans the
story of Hillsborough had come full
circle the fact that they've rerun these
old slurs has led this inquest to go on
much longer than it should have done and
that has caused great pain to the
families I know that and that's wrong
it's also led to tens of millions of
pounds of public money being spent on
lawyers and that is also wrong not one
scrap of evidence not one piece of video
or photographic evidence has been
produced in this inquest that backs up
the police case and so half police
officers still rerunning those old slurs
is quite frankly sickening
though the future may bring important
changes nothing can repair the damage of
the past and the pain for 27 years of
waiting for justice
you always say lordy juice 96 it's in
the hundreds because people who
committed suicide because of it people
have got ill water you know cause of it
it's just the past 27 years I still
think about it
sleepless nights [ __ ] nearing the wheels
here only you relive it again it's been
a cover-up they've covered things out
instead of being truthful
instead of being honest as they
portrayed the job to me at the beginning
when I first became a special ops
special constable if they had done that
then we wouldn't be here today
having to do with Hillsborough again I
was 23 at the time I'm 50 now it's as
though all my adult life I've lived
facing this battle grim was a decent
human being
we shouldn't still be here doing this so
many family members the passed away died
tormented like both my parents this
truth should have just been allowed to
come out back then in a 1989
[Applause]
[Music]
we're absolutely delighted my wife and I
that we we can look back and say that
ask we've done everything we can for our
son and his memory
the Jory Caron right this time I feel is
that this jury has taught everything in
that was getting certain the court over
these past two years it hasn't been easy
for them obviously well I think they
remembered it's not easy for the
families who were sitting there crying
but also praying at the same time just
prayed to James on the other ninety five
please God
son I want you to sleep well for the
first time I want you to rest in peace
now without seeing the Imams anger this
should have been the end quest that we
had twenty seven years ago it's over the
truth is one as far as I'm concerned
at long last this fight that we've had
on our hands now the whole world
believes what we were trying to tell
them twenty-seven years ago
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]